what is the dink existence really like
well this week there has also been for
whatever reason a sudden surge in Tik
Tok videos promoting this lifestyle
we're dinks we go to Trader Joe's and
workout classes on the weekends we're
dinks we get into snobby Hobbies like
skiing and golfing we're dinks we can go
to Florida on a win we're dinks we're
already planning our european vacation
next year dinks we get a full8 hours of
sleep and sometimes more we're dinks we
get desserts and appetizers at
restaurants we're dinks we can play with
other kids and give them back we're
dinks we still do it three times a week
we're dinks we don't use our kids or dog
as an excuse to leave a party we just
leave yes well I'm a cisk single income
six kids and I can do you one better I
make no excuse to leave a party because
I just don't go to parties in the first
place